hello everyone
based on the many many requests that i
have been receiving in the comments
sections of my
previous videos as well as on the
results of the poll
that i set up in the community post i
have decided to make a different sort of
video on giving some sort of advice for
jesus especially those who are dropping
or repeating
now
this is probably going to be my first
and last ever
video giving such advice for j
preparation
please note that i have myself never
trained anyone at the plus two level for
uh je
and i do not think i have the
expertise or the experience to give
expert advice on such things
nevertheless i have decided to make this
video
uh because i think that unlike many
other youtube channels where so-called
experts give advice
i don't have anything to sell
okay so i think
if i share some of my thoughts
it will be useful
for
the candidates who are dropping or
repeating to make some important
decisions please note that i'm not going
to give any uh specific tips on the
preparation of physics chemistry or
mathematics okay this is general advice
uh before we actually drop into uh or
jump into those pieces of advice i have
a little announcement to make a little
congratulate note uh to
a
young boy named krish agarwal who
successfully and was the first was was
the first student to correctly answer
the little question that i had posed in
one of my earlier videos regarding the
connection between zero thermodynamics
and python so congratulations krish i
had promised that i would mention his
name in the video so here it is
uh
jumping into the pieces of advice
the first thing that i would like you to
think about is that
where do you actually stand
okay what i mean by that is
do some introspection
and think about your actual position now
if you're dropping or repeating
suppose you have gotten admission
into
one of the nitis or a
good government college
in the context of west bengal here
i know of certain institutes for example
jadavpur university and iiast shipboard
which are more than excellent so if you
are in one of those nits
these kinds of very good colleges you
are all set you don't need my advice you
are at a stage of maturity and
preparation where you can decide for
yourself so you can close this video and
leave but just before leaving i'll just
say one thing that if you are suppose
uh thinking about preparing for je
second attempt uh then just be careful
not to screw up
uh your first year
results in the institute that you are
currently in
okay
so under no circumstances your first
year results of your current institute
should be hampered by your je
preparation of second attempt
next
suppose you are not you have not been
you have not gotten admission into
any of these nits or good government
colleges
or any other proper institute
then
i ask you to ask yourself this question
why is it that you did not get through j
and i don't just mean that you did not
get through je into iits i'm saying that
why didn't you even get into the nits or
a good college
why is that
now if the answer to your ques to this
question is that
you
needed more hard work
okay then i will ask you to be extra
extra careful to seriously rethink
because you see
this phrase
more hard work is needed
this is not something actionable
okay this is just like a hope that you
will do more hard work this time it is
actually worse than a hope it is a
fantasy
okay so
you seriously rethink if the only answer
to this question that why you did not
get through the first attempt is more
hard work
on the other hand
suppose your answer is that
you did not have the time to prepare
such and such topics and if you had
maybe two three months extra you could
have prepared those topics and then you
would have scored more maybe certain
questions had a combination of knowledge
from various topics and because you
because you were missing out on those
topics you were not able to answer a
number of questions in each of the
subjects
and that's why i did not get through now
that is very specific knowledge you can
that is something that you can actually
work on
all right so if that is your answer it's
good
suppose uh your answer is that
you
were at a level of preparation where you
knew the theory and you had the
knowledge but somehow you you were not
at the stage where you had the
sufficient speed to answer the questions
uh in the given time now that also is
something actionable you can work on it
you can improve you can get a better
rank next time
okay so
introspect think where you are standing
and think very very honestly don't let
anyone not even your parents your elder
siblings brothers sisters your seniors
and certainly not
the coaching
institute experts tell you where what
you want what you need you decide for
yourself and accordingly you prepare
this is my advice this is the main thing
that i wanted to talk about
again uh another important thing is
one year from now where do you see
yourself
okay this is something to think about
suppose let's say for argument's sake
that your preparation gets a little bit
better and you do manage to end up
let's say for arguments you could get up
and get into one of the iits let's say
for argument's sake uh you get into one
of the older iits okay
and so everyone is happy everyone is
congratulating you one year down the
line very happy
but in your heart you are not quite
happy because
uh
you did not get the branch or the
department which you were aspiring for
okay which you thought
is the best you did not get that
okay now i have seen in my experience
both as a student among my friends my
juniors as well as now that i am a
faculty here
at iit kharagpur i have seen this happen
to many many students that they somehow
join
the institute and have seen in other
institutions also that they just join it
and then
all throughout their college life they
suffer from some feeling of inferiority
which they have just built up in their
head
okay all throughout they suffer from
this feeling
and this feeling does not end here later
also in their career they just keep on
feeling like this so this is a very very
bad situation
what happens is that like what is more
dangerous is that these kinds of
students
uh
like not only do they do they not have
any interest because let's let's admit
here when you are just 17 18 19 years
old
i mean
you are not at a level of maturity that
you know what exactly your interest
could be
you don't even know the syllabus of the
various departments however the
dangerous thing is that some of these
students do not even have the
open-mindedness the flexibility
and the
persistence to kind of explore for
themselves
what the various
what the department has to offer one
important consideration which i would
like you to think about is that
let's say for argument's sake that you
join a certain department you are not at
all interested and
now nowadays
there is this uh
hype regarding uh
software jobs and you end up doing
taking up such a software job
all right very good you start earning a
salary and all those things but down the
line what happens do you think that
maybe as a civil engineer or a
mechanical engineer
you would be
able to grasp the kind of opportunities
which should otherwise be open for
students who have actually formally
trained in computer science or id
that is also something to think about
now these are rather high five things i
am talking about okay i know the ground
reality is that for many indian families
many middle class families
our situation is that
we will get some kind of a job so
going into iits nits or a good
government college is just like a
gateway for us to
get a good job okay this is the truth
so
if by getting that
the the good tag of the institute you
are able to land even if it is a
software job and it makes
somehow
your family life a little bit better and
that makes you happy
and that is the goal
i mean i support you all throughout okay
go ahead
i mean i mean get the tag get the job
whatever is whatever you can get
uh improve the situation of your family
because your first duty is certainly to
your family okay not to any higher order
philosophy
but
if you are the kind of person who has in
your heart
somewhat of a passion for
or interest or towards the actual
subjects that you are studying
maybe you are interested in higher
studies
then
it would be really unfortunate if you
stick around
for some uh some weird reason uh in a in
a in a department or studying a subject
so called studying a subject uh in which
you are least interested okay that would
be like a loss of your brain power
okay like your entire life you will be
left agonizing over your decision
okay
uh
i forgot to mention this i should have
mentioned this earlier that especially
for
people who are thinking of repeating
okay not people who have already dropped
or anything maybe who are thinking of
dropping or repeating and they have not
yet appeared for their board exams
please please be very very careful about
one thing
that no matter what you do in your
entrance
your board exam will come only once
okay and that result will stick around
to you with you all your life
nobody is going to ask you
what was what was your je rank but in
many many places especially especially
if you go into academia if you go into
higher studies people will ask you what
was your 10th board result what was your
12th boat result believe me i have gone
through this myself
uh even when i was applying for faculty
positions
i had to fill this up
okay you probably don't know these
things i had to fill well this up my
tenth would result my 12th boat racer
okay so suppose you have gotten a
position in your state board like then
that carries a lot of weight
okay certainly the institute and uh
which place you did your undergraduate
from what results you did all of these
things matter but your board results
also matter so please don't
please be very careful about that final
word of advice
remember that
je is not the end of your academic
career
okay
it may be the end of your school career
but your real career starts after je
okay so if you are stuck doing something
which you which every waking moment of
your life you
[Music]
you hate then it is almost equal to
like
like going into an arranged marriage
just because you
uh you want to satisfy the wish of your
parents of becoming grandparents
okay so remember it is your career not
anyone else's so please decide for
yourself thinking very very carefully so
this is all that i have to say thank you
very much and all the best in thinking
wisely